check out this week's must-see movies  not your job once I know in Blade Runner  2049 a detective seeks answers to long  buried secrets I always told you you're  special  after a tragic plane crash two strangers  must rely on each other to survive harsh  conditions in the mountain between us  nobody knows where we are we're all  we've got  we need help to save Equestria we're  ready to kick some booty in My Little  Pony the movie six friends embark on an  epic journey to save their community  y'all ponies are crazy see what's hot in  theaters with this week's fantasy  patient so what's your weekend ticket  going to be let us know by commenting  see you next time on weekend ticket  [Music]